[Music]
two of the men held responsible for one
of the deadliest nightclub fires in u.s
history are telling their side of the
story for the first time on tv club
owners jeff and michael derdarion faced
involuntary manslaughter charges after
100 people died and more than 200 people
were hurt in the 2003 fire it broke out
during a rock concert at the rhode
island nightclub the station for 48
hours jim axelrod spoke with some of the
survivors and learned some new
information that may help explain how
this tragedy happened
on february 20th 2003 at around 11 35 pm
jody king arrived at the station
nightclub in west warwick rhode island
his brother tracy worked there as a
bouncer
i see the horror and it was ugly the
roof was caving in walls were caving in
body after body in front of me
i don't even like to talk about
the fire started less than an hour
earlier when the band jack russell's
great white took the stage and their
tour manager set off four large
fireworks flames soon appeared on the
walls on either side and then it just
kept it kept growing jeff daddarian and
his brother michael owned the club it
was happening so fast fast fast fast
that's all i just can keep seeing in my
head
and the the the roof and just everything
just
passed too fast a hundred people
perished including jody's brother
over 200 people were injured we're sorry
for all of it and if we could change it
we would
nine months after the fire the dadarian
brothers along with daniel beakley great
white's tour manager were each charged
with 200 counts of involuntary
manslaughter they all eventually took
plea deals beakley and michael didarion
served time in prison we never knew the
whole story
because the trial never happened
so everything really never came out but
now 18 years later the brothers say they
want to set the record straight
why are you sitting here talking to me
we
wanted the full story to come out not
just some of it and that for people who
want to come to their own conclusion
on what happened that night
jim maxwell joins us right now jim why
did the nightclub burn down so quickly
right that's the key to the entire story
how quickly and how widely the flames
spread the brothers had received
complaints from their neighbors about
the sound coming out of the club so they
decided to install some foam on the
walls of the club to dampen the sound
problem is that foam was an accelerant
it spread it almost was described to me
as hanging solid gasoline on the walls
of the club but did they know that it
doesn't seem like that they would have
installed it if they knew that it could
be that dangerous crucial point this
will get into a lot tomorrow night on 48
hours but key point is the brother said
they ordered non-flammable sound foam
but got highly flammable packing foam
they produced the facts that showed
their order requested the sound foam and
this is a key critical part of the story
and part of this new information we'll
get into tomorrow night wow jim thank
you so much and speaking of tomorrow you
can watch jim's report the station
nightclub fire who's responsible
tomorrow night on 48 hours at 10 9
central right here on cbs